on va suivre la ce parti d'asd l aréna
francophones d'afrique francophone
francophonie cas non c'est plus tard son
italien ans a avoué pariant l'a accepté
les cia et castello l aréna elle arrive
à être partie d'al partie des
costes-rouges guindo arrête béral aux
sociétés comme tra et ensaia et
lorsqu'on regarde au reste des francia
perron perron blanco ctt tt tt nerfs et
ténéré et dosser dos péronnas menos et
la dame a atteint cas le fou m'en aller
on sent pas bon alors atteint que le
fouet f3 on attaque bessette et anne
sayah ont su heures face à cette dame f3
la sueur à grosses gouttes ce talus à
speed and salua twitch switch permet de
foncer 8 soit se faire [ __ ] en d3 moi
je dis et je dis ça je dis rien j'ai
l'impression de bérat l'eau il est chaud
et ça rime en plus berra l'eau il est
chaud
j'ai l'impression qu'il a réussi son
ouverture il va il va faire flouer
quatre grands rock il ya du cavalier b5
qui traînent ya de la découverte as en
âge sept ans j'ai 6
ça sent la manchester ada pour pour
ethan ça sent la manchester à la
sécherie nettement ses shows à défendre
battue je me demandais mais ce que gros
rock est un coup quoi je te laisse le
fou je te colle un échec je te fais
pousser 4 je te fais tu te fais tête
grand roque tu bouffes le truc je te
fais pousser catch attack f7 chp a pas
que la dame je t'attaque tous rejoint tu
achètes attaque assez chaud franchement
franchement les mecs e5 grand roque
candidats palmarès de croix que je donne
une pièce en a mais je menace ou c4
franchement c'est choquant requins
franchement les mecs qui dans le chatt
pense que c'est un coup intéressant
grand roque salua france
jacques est un père à taureaux et 91 xxx
salute salute bienvenido à nidau elle
serait mais est fou j'ai trois mais tu
vois honnêtement les mecs dans le chatt
al et j'aimerais bien qu'on me dise dans
le chat qui aurait fait grand roque ici
avec une coupure de couilles en acier
puis on prend et poussé quatre dégage
avec ton pion qui aurait fait ça
françois jacq il aurait fait grand roque
alors franchement on aurait tous ces
grands rock ici on aurait tous ces
grands
alors là parce que je propose tête c'est
grand roque quand même on laisse faire
h3 alors ok quand on voit qu'il a eu
peur de fou g4 évidemment l'avais pas vu
marie lafarge 3 matches 3 ses petits
bras
pequeno pequeno pequeno
pequeno bryce et marcher dessus la
caisse qui ne fédéral hall à qu'est ce
qui nous fédère à l'eau ils reculent ils
reculent berra lors qu allez-vous c4
avance à l'étape sur le pion à vii berra
l'eau allez on veut voir du jeu là on
veut voir de l'attak béral aux migrants
qui est peut-être fou gk pillai pas du
tout vient aulas est le professeur et
groot est aulas quel talent pequeno ruga
d'or tour aller on veut envoyer là allez
on veut du fou prend 1,7 à une menace
est fou prend h celle qui est pratiquée
pour un f3 prend achète et tour prend
des gars allez fait cavalier prend h7
regarde qu'elle prend h7 fou prend h
73.7 tour prend des quatre pions quand
des cas dame prend 1,8 prison huit
prisons huit prix se trois attaques as
deux mois
palmarès de la variante j'ai perdu une
pièce à les fonds envoyés la foule prend
1,5 à lécher pas mais font voyez-vous
prendre 5 ça gagne un pion faut envoyer
quelque part la libérale auber à l'ol
n'a plus qu'une minute alors on envoie
haberal au bout me viennent à l'esprit
ce prise assez bien jouer maintenant le
cavalier a attaqué il ya tout proche
cet échec pour compter 8 qui arrive
ah il est bien berra l'eau beraldo il
est chaud est là il est bien français
trois années en fait faut prendre 5 bien
joué et verra la der à l'eau qui
attaquent comme une brute c'est ça qu'on
veut voir vert allô c'est ça le beau jeu
elle bonito moncade reiber à l'eau a
laissé bien jouer des rats l'eau c'est
bien joué j'ai presque envie d'appeler
bière à l'eau allez bim dame à d'un
premier cas il peut pas bon alors là il
peut faire peut-être binh phu proches
cet échec déjà pour commencer est à
prévoir mais de faire des trucs violent
genre souvent h cette fois et fuite fou
quand j'essaie trois projets cette dame
prend des quatre échecs et il fait
tomber le cavalero quoi bon après faut
bien calculer mais ça ça va quand même
pas mal parce que sur wash si ça peut
être même d'un match 4 échecs encore pu
tout reprend des 5
ouais vous pour vous prend h7
honnêtement fourrage cette frange et ça
ça a l'air pas mal
bon il fait dame prend des cats et sur
deux points il va faire f 4 c'est très
bien aussi un bon dam des huit fautes ou
défendre je pense seul coup peut-être
quatre ans un petit c4 ou un petit truc
mais bon il survit quoi
il faut prolonger son arrêt juste de me
prends des cinq noms parce que damas
trois échecs j'ai envie de dire ballet
thomas leroy et ayora fou au 6ième joue
pas mal et anaïs défend pas mal les
ressources foule et anin c'est pas la
première fois qu'on le voit trouver des
ressources
je crois qu'il l'a possiblement
magouiller fou aussi cela c'est quand
même fort bah c'est bien joué de la part
des fans ils magouillent pas mal ce
petit ethan est dangereux il faut faire
dame b ça il faut venir couvrira faut
venir colmatée
amira fou prend à deux quand même mais
peut-être qui colmate rien et donc tu es
fou des six intermédiaire c'est bien
joué
ah mais c'est c'est embêtant pour
[Musique]
peut-être y aurait pu faire fou prend
cet échec du coup droit prend dam des
trois essais 4 est comme ça il a le fou
qu'il n'ait colmater bon je sais pas il
n'a pas été assez tranchants temps à
prendre est maintenant il a roi c'est un
bon ça va être chaud cette partie les
mecs on commence par une belle partie un
droit des deux c'est être un poil
prématurée il y avait peut-être f5 ici
qui semblait intéressant parce que il y
avait un clouage après c'était peut-être
pas fini avait dû à six avait des trucs
ok ça échange ces carrières où pranger
de il le rate
allez faut bouger le pion gb rallo abera
look ivoirien berra l'eau qui sut ici
issoufou au tour g1 aux fous prend h3
raté la catastrophe adha ça craque ayad
de par twilight 4 h 5 vite quake 3 h 5
boubou froid droit ces trois des quatre
avait pas toi aller vers à l'eau monte
le roi a laissé bien
trois des quatre
même auriez malin vous prend comprend il
est mal le roi peut pas venir peut pas
rentrer en fait un cas est ce pas très
bien joué ça décape maintenant aller au
nom pourquoi tu fais ça tu donnes roi de
7 à pourquoi il a fait touriste il
fallait faire des quatre directs à
l'étranger un col matin c'est bien joué
maintenant il ya paroisse et fils seront
appréhendés 6 7 pions le pion tombe pour
apprendre et 6 aller et on pousse on
pousse on pousse et tu pousse pousse
pousse et petits pions passé à l'e3
c'est cette pousse pousse
non pas tour est fait un pouce va
pousser on s'en fout de tours f1 sa
censure aux recettes et les tours d un
et affaires bessac
et ouais nan t'as plutôt g4 à son roi ce
faire on s'est peut-être pas si mal je
déconne croise et 7 il va la tenir à
l'est vers à l'opéra l'opéra l'opéra
l'eau à les rois b737 3 6 7 revient là
et annie va être obligé de faire j'ai
quatre envoyés le pion passé il faut
tenter de la gagne elle a été adroit
c'est cette étape palmarès des tannes
joue à jouer g4 qu'est ce qui fait en
fait tu vois tu dois faire j'ai quatre
oies c6 horrible g4 maintenant arrive tu
as perdu un temps tu as perdu un temps
crois c'est cette force et il ya tous
rêvent qu'à tours f4 tout 24 tours f4
intéressant tour f4 c'était vraiment
intéressant idée tout reprend 17 tours
angers 4 échecs wife 5tourcoing quatre
signaux le new light and faut faire
rager 5 on voyait ton pions essayé de
passer le pion à jeu qu'on reste qu'il
faut en fait je comprends pas ce qu'ils
font en tout cas pour l'aréna ces deux
bonnes nouvelles pour tous les autres
tours f4 tout rêve car pourquoi touré
fuite
mme marois g50 f4 et c'est nul ils
savent pas te roi puis on saigne le fait
qu'ils connaissent pas juste 3g cinq
sites en fout des huîtres au f4
brisebois f4 très important au f4 par
watch quatre bons g3 marois d53 ici et
là voient ces cas tu vient colmater ce
pion parce que tu veux pas jouer au con
de toute façon tu quoique tour f8
rouages et 3 mois non ok maintenant je
fais 3 c3 tu va bloquer celui-là
pourquoi avoir des 3,3 ces deux tons
rouabah venger celui-là et toi paraître
l'autre non mais attends il met en pls
qu'il a il a perdu ça il va perdre ça ou
c'est pas perdant c'est incroyable oh
ils mettent en pls
ils m'ont mis en pl ace ils sont 2000
les mecs il va la perdre
mais monde jusque vers la tour ils m'ont
mis en non non ils mettent en pl j'en
peux plus je n'en peux plus monte vers
la tour monde vers la tour et tu vas
d'aller un des deux pions non tout comme
à nantes ou rouen
voilà peut-être il pouvait pas le faire
par dont peut-être s'il pouvait pas le
faire
ils m'ont mis en pl ace ok c'est moi qui
ai déconné sur le dernier truc mais les
techniques de défense ont tellement
folle mais maintenant il ya géant dames
mais hier j'ai un homme mais j'ai un
dame ça gagne pas à temps c'est moi qui
hallucine géant dames palmarès deux
géants dames tourcoing d'orwell froissé
gagner tout reprend gérard on apprend et
adamo prochain oh là là ils m'ont mis en
pl ace mayroy froid 2 mais qu'ils y font
mouche y comprend rien ils le font
exprès c'est pas possible in troll c'est
pas possible c'est pas possible il me
troll
ils sont en train de me trop laisse pas
possible ils vont trop laid ok il veut
quand il veut laisser faire croire non
mais il me trois là c'est pas possible
il va il veut ils veulent me rendre
chèvre mais attends mais maintenant il
ya juste trois ans 2,01 m 2 non mais
attends c'est pas possible c'est pas
possible tout non mais attends c'est pas
possible il y avait dames en 1 qu'elle
attendait on s'est fait trois là c'est
pas assez incroyable c'est incroyable
j'ai rien compris j'ai rien compris
bon là je me suis trompé quand j'ai dit
montée vers un verre à la tour en fait
ça marchait pas en fait ils pouvaient le
faire mais pas les faire comme ça watch
quatre là y'a pas tour congé d'eux il ya
un mam torah je suis 3g 5 qui a pas tous
rachats tour g 8 3 à 6 tours à je suis
3g c'est ce que j'avais vu au début mai
mais ils vont ils m'ont ils montrent les
de folie c'est ce soit et montre au lait
soit je comprends pas non mais là
c'était hallucinant et la fin c'est
hallucinant j'ai jamais vu ça les mecs
j'ai jamais vu ça jamais là à temps
pourquoi il fait pas d'âme
pourquoi il fait pas d'âme je comprends
rien ils m'ont mis en pl ace de niveau
10 mille c'est hallucinant c'est parce
que vous en pensez dans le chat commet
comment comment vous réagissez
ils m'ont mis en pl ace honnêtement
l'agent peut plus là là je crois quand
une partie
je crois quand une partie je suis je
suis je me suis fait mais tempérait de
niveau mille jamais vu ça incroyable je
me suis fait je me suis ça y est je suis
en position latérale de sécurité là j'ai
juste rien compris
les mais qu'est-ce que dans le chat
dites moi vous pensez qu'on s'est fait
troll par ses deux mains qui sont mis
d'accord pour d'autres rôles et un
disque dur qu'on a patrol franchement
vous m'avez 3 les mecs c'est pas
possible moi j'y crois pas je me suis
fait troll à un truc de fou ce que vous
avez fait un truc de fou mais mitroglou
il aurait mieux jouer cette finale
non franchement j'y crois pas je veux
pas y croire les mecs je veux pas y
croire n'oubliez pas de foule au la
chaîne under si vous êtes nouveau peut
mettre le petit follow la chaîne chasse
com fr il fait toujours plein ouest
françois jacky 10 ha ut roll non mais là
j'ai besoin de retrouver mes esprits des
mannequins désolé mais là après après ce
qu'on vient de voir
franchement j'ai besoin d'une petite
minute de récupération là c'était trop
c'était vraiment too much les mecs
c'était vraiment too much
vous m'avez mis en sueur les mecs y sont
quand même super mal joué voilà berra
l'opa par ailleurs qui est en train de
faire une bonne partie l'envoie sur le
roi pourquoi tu joues pas aussi mal
quand tu joues contre moi et anne c'est
quoi le délire
voilà vous allez voir un math à ses fins
c'est un truc hyper typique 1 ce qui
fait il a mis les pieds au 4 f3 vous
avez vu quatre f3 il envoie les
mobylettes et il va ouvrir le roi
adverse il va mater avec les blancs ça
va être un chef-d'oeuvre
d'ailleurs on en train de regarder un
chef-d'oeuvre
j'ai vieilli au 13 du temps tu peut les
critiquer mais la majorité du chat
amiens - que leur classement donc la
critique est facile et gégé en sueur
ben on a devant nous réussir je la fais
des finales de merveilles m'ont quand
même trop lent mais je lis un moment
donné c'était juste que je sais pas si
vous vous rappelez vous rappelez de la
partie km/heure vacon contre démentait
la critique qui la partie créé km heure
contre démentez et démantèle était mort
de rire quoi c'est c'est peut-être une
des pires partie de sa vie qu'elle ait
gagné
c'était hallucinant cette partie c'était
hallucinant et même des des salles a
fait marrer après quand elle a vu là il
va était morte de rire parce que j'étais
en paix à l'aise de niveau 10 mille quoi
ni moi même at elle rêvait même enfin
les deux m'ont mis en pl ace évidemment
c'est bien fini pour nous c'était génial
ils ont donné pièce sur pièce alors
qu'ils sont bons ces îles sont 2005 les
deux et ils jouent vraiment bien quads
et des allées plus forte que moi et
gamer aussi mais la partie c'était
hallucinant quoi c'était cadeau sur
cadeaux ils ont fait n'importe quoi
c'était hallucinant way françois jacq
pas avoir fait géant dames c'est vrai
que c'est spécial quoi il on craque
adéquat non plus et orrit pour eux parce
que vu le format de l'aréna la partie a
duré super longtemps
donc ils ont ils ont mis presque fils
ont joué pendant quasiment un quart
d'heure je savais et civelli sur une
news
aucun des deux qui auraient eu même
l'espoir d'un strict ça aurait été
violent mais du coup ça allait vraiment
l'espoir aux autres parce que ce genre
de parties très longue
pendant ce temps là les autres ont eu le
temps de jouer deux voire même trois
parties pour certains et donc c'est
chaud
quelle folie quand même impressionnant
ce qu'on vient de voir un c j'ai du mal
à vous remettre les mecs j'ai du mal à
m'en remettre
est-ce que ça a écrit j'ai du mal à m'en
remettre
et ce qui est mieux que h6 pour l'attack
bas âge si c'est pas idiot en fait dans
le sens où tu ça va mettre la tour en
pls après moi j'aurais peut-être plus
tôt fait pions prend mariés entourés
pardon h cinq tours à schwyz ouais ça
met la tour en perdre et c'est là où
j'en étais et non ça me paraît pas mal
l'idée c'est de sept blocs qui sait
jouer avec une tour de plus en fait
moi je trouve pas ça si mal après ce
qu'on aurait eu d'autres options
moi j'aime bien perso face à ces
thématiques en tout cas prêt à faire
réussir à faire j'ai 5 à 4 et puis f5 et
tout ouvrir sur le roi mais du coup les
noirs et donc un mini tour de moins en
jeu ainsi c'est quand même assez
thématique ben trucks qui avait fait
peut-être fallu réussir à jouer g5 plus
vite pour les blancs un petit mois c'est
plus car ils étaient 5 avec n'ai pas
trop aimé je vous demande si on pouvait
pas faire g5 pour commencer l'essai
lecavalier partir vers h5 kf4 lecavalier
chez pas oui part on va dire peut-être
angers car je sais pas et maintenant est
organisée du tour ff5 est en fait du
coup on a vraiment glauque et les noirs
et si la dame arrive un jour en 1 4 ce
soir ces festivals en 2000 on remet ça
légal et c'est la totale quoi j'ai envie
de dire pour ceux qui comprennent les
références moi j'aurais plutôt fait
comme ça on va dire on nous propose
âgées damage this way mais sur hg il
faisait à alger et du coup la tour
colmatée pas si simple
je pourrais peut-être essayé de pousser
mais même là ça me paraît être la grosse
sueur pour aller noir saatchi g5 f4 pour
vraiment prendre de l'espace et bloqué
la tour et après jouer avec une tour de
plus sur le reste de l'échiquier mais a
noté qu' eric et ramzy joue bien alors
est ce que c'est c'est tu voi le mec
s'appelle eric et ramzy est ce qu'on a
le droit d'être deux sur un même compte
qu'on ne sais pas moi et tout reprendre
et si c'était cadeau ça a été raté
beraldo qui en sûr quand même par
rapport à la première partie
clairement ça là bon il va quand même la
gagner mais il a il pourrait gagner plus
vite contre un joueur qui me les calques
qui se défend bien par ailleurs mais
quand même la différence de lots devrait
jouer et là un petit dame prend des sept
équidés dame prend tout reprendre et on
prend pour des huit matchs peut-être
peut-être pas on ne sait pas non quand
même pas manquer et c'est ça que ça
gagne aussi la position est tellement
écrasante mais ont juste d'un premier
set gagné une pièce en est quand même
voix la dame prend 17 peut-être quand
même oui cavale et prend menace cavalier
a aussi séché d'impro f6 d'amd 8 la
qualifie ces chèques quand même pour
finir proprement
ça a été gagnée mais beranek qui utilise
beaucoup de temps pour gagner c'est les
arénas faut essayer d'être plus efficace
contre un adversaire à 1100 milles point
éloquent même des cars ont peut être
plus efficace
364 qui demande war in one is ariana qui
immigraient j'ai envie de te dire ces
instruments français mais on va te
répondre quand même de rouina king is in
about and are one hour of course welcome
to play et même un ultime tournoi stream
ya une origine il ya un diamant a gagné
banias toujours en moi diamant a gagné
un prix faux mail et/ou
bon alors qu' on suit ce jeu s'appelle
vous allez ont reçu berra le nom va pas
toujours super aloha private en sueur
allez on va regarder et anne contre
nirvan accueillir vanak
cette finale on aime bien nirvana accès
c'est un mec ça fait un moment qui suit
l'estrie nirvana que je pense qu'il
était beaucoup plus faible quand il a
commencé à suivre les screen il pourra
nous dire peut-être dans le chat s'il
est là nirvana cnir mann act et là on
fait chier en fait ils disaient leur
train de jouer le contre avec 1600
poillot de plus que l'huile en sueur et
il ya un conte qui lui demande s'il veut
depuis longtemps à l'est d'alger 5 la
machine s'est emballée à calais contre
je viens je n ai qu il écoute
non mais tu as dame et à damien place
place soit coiffes et wap l'aise après
tu mets les pions h4 tes maîtres de tout
tu défends tout ils essayent de mathieu
rohan ps c'est bien ce qui fait qu'ils
débarrassent du pion h et il tient ses
faiblesses il peut faire nul nirvana qui
s'ils s'appliquent il peut faire du
lycée il fallait reprendre de f
peut-être à je sais pas moi j'aurais
tenté le coup franc pour essayer d'avoir
un plan clair damev 6h 5h 4 et envoyer
le pion faire un pion passé mais il a
voulu reprendre vers le centre et anne
et maintenant la dame va venir en h3 et
ça va être dur j'aurais repris de f1 il
n'a pas fait d'un mât choix donc il n'a
pas il n'a pas bloqué il a pas bloquer
f5
il ya quand même beaucoup d'erreurs au
nirvana que l'afo touche à rien et c'est
bien ce qui fait qu'ils aient atteint
juste un petit coup deux à quatre pour
éviter de se prendre une poussée prendra
un peu d'espacé après tu attends quoi tu
attends tu t'assieds tu fumes j'avais un
copain qui disait ça en russie en ruine
bien celui de la mise à jour tu
t'assieds tu fumes au g4 crise
pourquoi t'as fait ça pourquoi t'as fait
ça on va bien vous me trolls et les mecs
c'est pas possible le pétrole nirvana
qui est en train de faire une grosse
perf nirvana qui était bien dans le game
or il était chaud nirvana pourquoi t'as
fait ça me remet anac
j'ai envie de chialer nirvana je suis
dégoûtée je suis dégoûtée nirvana qui
était bien dans le game franchement ils
avaient annuler un nirvana qu un faux
constats remis à manhac après un coup
c'est tabou pourquoi il a fait ça
du coup on va arriver la partie suivante
bah ouais t'as du coup vous pouvez tous
participé d'ailleurs à l'aréna temps je
vais m comment comment participer
attendait m'étais tellement sueur je
vais vous m comment participer vous
m'avez vous mettant sur la nirvana qui
m'a mis en sueur c'était pas loin de
faire la paire fin tu étais pas loin du
yatenga tang acquis 1
il est stressé plus qu'au bas quoi es tu
nous as mis en sueur un c'est dommage je
vais faire copier coller
noma jerman a quand tu étais pas loin on
espérait surtout à nirvana qu'un aléa
s'est dit content rochefort pas de
chance ni robin mc la chante la main
c'est dommage tu as bien joué en fait
c'est pour ça qu'on est déçu pour toi
faut faire gaffe ya peut-être ça tient
faut assister à ces quatre à temps x 6
et 4 f5 et apoel 3 parce que sur f5 sur
fou prend f5 à [ __ ] ans et 4 mai sur
f5 apoel 3 il tient tout y est un gars
qui
sur f5 fois f3 important ce que je peux
afficher le classement demande et après
je peux match au classement elias qui a
pris le lead ses singles et maintenant
il ya foot et 5 qui arrive tour 5 et le
pion c5 qui va tomber
super nanny que je suis mini motion sera
peut-être championnat de france
attention il ya des cetc le thunder des
joueurs d'échecs maintenant les stream
attention parce que minime ça peut
porter à confusion à la confusion qu on
ne sait pas minime
tu as un mini minimes masculins féminins
tu en sais pas peut-être des couples qui
sont en train de se former pendant ces
stream acebo [ __ ] plein coûte peut
être intéressant ce tour d2 les finales
de pions sont gagnantes et si on te fait
fou quand tu peux faire c'est prend et
au moins tu as les mobylettes l'os
mobile et ans
tentez tour des deux personnes est les
rois des 3 4 des 5 cubains de l'autre
côté il ya d'un gars qui la chante là
j'en peux plus je n'en peux plus je n'en
peux plus je me fais trolls dans toutes
les parties j'en ai marre ça chagrine
les taxis je suis mis moi aussi on se
perd en forme et toi je moi je me dis un
problème allez assister bien jouer bravo
3 ou 4 mois les tours deux tours deux
tours aussi ce tonton
il va pas la gagner a dit
chagrine taxe -saluée chagriné par les
taxes ouais très taxée 1
j'y comprends rien cette finale il va la
perdre
palmarès de didier 1984 je vais perdre
la finale sur un sur un trébuchet
tu vas voir oh là là c'était sûr c'était
écrit mais peut-être qu'il peut être
n'ont ils veulent me tuer quoi mais
peut-être que là il se connaître et
bûcher mais peut-être qu'il réussissait
à achopper le pion de l'autre côté
yatenga qui atteignent acquis et et
peut-être que ça allait mais roy pays si
si mme halima alimamy en sueur il a
perdu de temps et maintenant hyper bien
sûr juste va bouffer h5
voilà maintenant on va bouffer h5
sacrifie toi conques le pion effet dame
arrêtez de me faire suer les mecs s'il
vous plaît beaucoup h 5
ok mais nos rois b2 ok ok ça
il nourrit m'ont fait peur il m'a fait
peur dit vous nous fait peur les mecs un
sérieux vous me faites peur allez
d'escaut des terres contrat signé à nice
c'est chaud
compeyre franchement ils font peur en
finale à moi je vais arriver à l'aréna
king ce soir derrière je vais je vais je
fais attention je vais pas réussir à
jouer je vais être déjà crevé avant le
début quoi vous vous me tuez les mecs à
l'est d'amiens autour des 1 dames g3 à
rien et on voit aller on en voit aller
d'escaut des terres assez musclé parti
pour mille soit fait soit
les gentils messages de famille
bon du coup
je fais juste à fabas fab libye message
et on est reparti non mais j'ai besoin
de faire des petites pauses parce qu'en
fait c'est trop dur
du coup on a on est quoi on va revenir
sur sur la partie allez hop
ce message habibi ça fait toujours
plaisir je suis tant qu essayer de
suzanne qui est bloqué à nous regarder
pas de chance par desko des terres et ce
qui perd vraiment le pion ou pas vont
ils faire cavalier à quatre épreuves
catways trois tours des quatre bombes
taurin et ça va non mais ok ça toi c'est
quoi cette position n'a pas évolué comme
un fouet f3 il ya id2 vous prend à 8
bouffer fin voile est inné de
probablement ce que tour des caps toi je
la sens pas mais quel est des deux mais
il n'avait pas bu fouet f3 en fait olala
et a pris dans le quatier pas eu faux f3
et mecs faut calculer quand même les
échecs il faut quand même un peu c'est
un jeu d'anticipation 1 ap 7 kgs
salanquais cinq fois à 8 pardon mais
quel est des deux comme très logique qui
a aidé deux fois huit cavaliers afin
bouffer fin vous faisiez move machin
autour des 1 et idées sur tour des huit
bouffe bouffe et roy e 2 et de se dire
que le roi mon viseur les pions mais il
avait pas vu quand avec les prendre 4 x
3 fin quand même calcul un peu à
l'avance états unis fonction rakotomavo
pour le t-shirt crois que tu mates ou
envoyer un mail bon faut que je l'envoie
maintenant du coup comme j'ai un emploi
du temps assez chargé
ça prend un peu de temps quoi c'est pas
si simple à envoyer en fait c'est chiant
mais je t'ai envoyé t'inquiète pas ça va
bien se passer ne t'inquiète pas
les princes après face à g tour d un
tour des huit
on va voir tour à 8 3 2
tour des bitumes anciens vous faire
touret fuite probablement et fouache 4
way où ça c'est bien joué ça bravo tour
des deux fous j'ai 5 km ces trois bus c3
vous du caïman fu b4 bien sur tourbe et
huit tombes et j'aime pas quoique
peut-être pas mal
la demande si on fait tourner dans la
sphère foulée 4 2 où est-ce qu'on fait
cavalier à 4 mai khai et a4 j'aime
pascal y en a quatre têtes b3 mais mon
tour ici c'est chiant ça fait retour des
deux fous békaa 3 de bouffe bouffe
s'il fait un petit boost bouffe et après
c'est monté le roi m'a charmant je sais
pas trop en fait il faut les cinq
maintenant on tourne au t3 un machin tu
colles ma tête envoie les pions après me
racheter pas à bouger 5 je suis assez
soupçonnant de ce coup je vois pas
vraiment ce que le fou a réussi en fait
ici palmarès du foot je vais repartir f6
quoi sa tête avec les blancs peut faire
b 3 4 a lieu quatre et c5
la recette du coup tours d2 je vois pas
trop ce que ça à deux chiffres vraiment
monter le roi à quoi je pense c'est un
peu une perte de temps kerouay f3 autour
desquels autour des cats autour des
quatre tours ces deux noms qui est
autour des 4 c'est peut-être car elles
quatre ces deux tours ses sept tours à
cette adresse sur réussi à faire ça en
fait des rois du pétrole pour ces sept
pays ces cinq et qui est pas important
autour pour ces deux g4 boubou froid et
3g 4 aussi à la rigueur d'alger cats
étaient pas con j'ai cassé mais malin
peut-être tu fixes ça l'a tué ton cahier
du coup il est maître du pétrole bon ok
pas très grave et n'auront pas fou g53
des trois tours des cats parce qu'il ya
cavaliers prend hélas du coup ils
menacent tour c'est cette es6 doit faire
tour d'essai tué avoir tour c'est si ces
machins et avec les noirs ici et là pas
senti qu'il fallait prendre le cavalier
en fait il n'y a pas compris que
lecavalier a eu quatre ils allaient
d'être très dominant à leur tour ces six
tours à cet essai 5 machin roi ou 4e 6 3
f 5 à 6 tours à six auxquelles ces cinq
quand même caisse et 5 quand même mieux
tomber cinq tours échec tour revient et
trois ou quatre wife cinq ans il s'est
fait dominer il n'a pas compris le roi
car à 3 prendre cinq as roi où il y
avait un joli piège trois ou quatre
tours bk 3.5.6 matt mignon ça s'était
bien joué mais je pense que j'aurais
créés n'a pas bien compris les enjeux
stratégiques de la position et la tour e
6 tourcoing 50 imagine
parce que quand même c'est un pion dans
ses pions de plus comme ça surtout f4 à
peut-être même tour cat échanges en
force
je crois et / ou assistent accueilli 17
points à 5
jusqu'à m'intéressant de taper à 5 psg
trois rois f3 solide et est content
qu'ils aient mis depuis en g3 bon il a
tenté un piège qu'on apprend j'ai trois
fois f4 mais bon ça c'est au pitch sc tu
joues pour un piège est en fait à au roi
prend croître en g3 fait c'était ben
quoi tu as joué pour un piège et tu as
perdu en pions pas de chance
et en plus sur roy g6 à tour prend cinq
cavaliers ou six c'est dommage qu'il
n'ait pas qui n'est pas puni pour avoir
vu pour un piège mais tu as jeu pour un
piège très bien quoi et tu fais le chan
reec toi ok ça c'est nul main non mais
il aurait pu punir pour avoir joué pour
un piège et gagner la partie tout de
suite qu'elle évidemment tu dois jamais
accepté nul avec les blancs la jouer
mais malheureusement c'est une arena tu
ne vas pas la gagner bon c'est nul
théorique j'en ai tenu une d'ailleurs un
dans un title tuesday c'est dommage
et n'oubliez pas de follow la chaîne les
mannequins attention tout le monde
follow mois il va encaisser le pion à
surtout ne pas échanger les tours quand
tu encaisses qui coup droit à b4
lancastre avec le cavalier bien
évidemment moi j'aurais bien collé deux
trois petits et chaque avant pour voir
ce qu'ils essaient de tenter des pièges
ok maintenant faut piégée donc je serai
bien un petit échec ce soir de provoquer
roi des cinq mais fertile et 6 tentés il
fait parler maintenant
à ce niveau là ça va pas être simple à
défendre à voler pour les noirs et moi
j'ai défendu une attention je le redis
parce que je suis fier c'est la première
fois que j'en défends des mines de ma
vie et j'ai réussi à la défendre
50 coup et donc je suis assez fier c'est
pas super dur à défendre mais bon après
il attaque pas super mini clé le roi
doit vraiment aller pour pousser droit
adverse
on sait pas ce qui fait quoi
il se couvre trop tôt sa galère un
touriste y aller on monte le roi machin
bon pour le moins d'air mais c'est pas à
toi six échecs aux îles propre à la tour
pourquoi je fait chialer [ __ ] les
tours des six fait des progrès roi ici
non comment vous pourquoi vous faites ça
les mecs
pourquoi vous me fait ça pour quoi
pourquoi qui sait ces types pourquoi tu
fais pas tourner 6 3 et 6 et u tentent
de progresser
et toi pourquoi tu fais pas tout raciste
et dispute a et b
pourquoi vous contrôler autant pourquoi
qu'est ce que j'ai fais quoi qu'est ce
que je vous ai fait les mecs
est ce que je vous ai fait issou
je suis en sur les batteries qu'est ce
que j'ai fait au bon dieu pour que pour
regarder ça sent mauvais karma option en
un il me fait yanis au nom ils veulent
me tuer il va le mach vais tuer le match
v les fake
olala il faut il me faut une faux ils
meurent faut en temps je voir ce que fab
ubi écrit parce que j'en peux plus quoi
parce que fable il a écrit fabi
m'écrivent fut créé citant femme lui je
crois qu'il m'a écrit un truc pareil
j'en peux plus les mecs
ce soir j'ai incarne un mauvais karma
quoi je n'avais jamais vu ça
ils m'ont fait mal sérieux vous m'avez
fait mal les mecs ce que je mange avant
les arénas ouais je vais essayer de
manger mais j'ai un peu mal au ventre
mais en fait ça je sais pas quand j'ai
commencé à avoir mal au ventre après vos
conneries et je ne rigole pas en fait je
regarde vos parties là et sérieux je
commence à avoir un peu mal à l'estomac
ou à l'intestin ou je sais pas quoi
je me sens un peu vallonné je vais
peut-être prendre du yaourt au bifidus
actif
ça va faire beaucoup de bien le bifidus
difficile si c'est très intéressant nous
écrit dans le chatt wiki strike c'est
pas des pros ils ont le droit à l'erreur
non ben non pas j'ai le droit non t'as
pas le droit je sais pas si comprend que
c'est du semis troll après vous parliez
qui éprouvent aussi ce qui est prend des
8es qui est prouvée 7 enfin deux
variantes j'espère que ça va voir quand
même là parce que sinon on n'en peut
plus
non mais le problème c'est que c'est un
manque race le cerveau là le regard des
salons mais franchement les mecs l'info
oh là là en plus passeur pour la dame
sur échec
yanis ans sur yanis issue après sa
partie précédente donc au classement
eupen qui a pris l'ina malgré un début
difficile on va revoir un peu berra
l'eau pour voir s'il peut répondre
il opère allô allô là il est gagnant
vous m'avez fait souffrir ont fait
souffrir
vous utilisez toute mon énergie vitale
quoi enfin vous êtes incorrigible par
adam français si ce boom qui oui parce
qu'on va reçu béral au pouvoir cyber à
l'eau peut nier ou berlin peut répondre
quoi
non mais c'était incroyable à tout ce
qu'on a vu un franchement attendait la
crypte allociné dans le cadre de trucks
mack est acquis et superman une pièce de
moi
ce qu'ils veulent arnaquer ou pas on va
voir ça on va voir ça ensemble et on
plomb à faire peut-être un petit coup de
ces quatre un moment ça marche le plus
silver and hacker croll apprend à sa
tête pour aller prendre du matos ça
défend
super génial qui peut gagner parce que
super bien et en rapport avec tortue
géniale d'ailleurs on ne sait pas aller
à 4 à 5
ça va être chaud la mairie qui espions
plus mais à 600 points et rodez car
c'est chaud jamais envoyé le pion à si
j'étais les noirs peut-être comme si on
passait un peut-être là qu'il ya là plus
de facilité à jouer
alors s'ils arrivent à 0 secondes sur le
compteur hyper oui oui tout à fait mais
il ya deux secondes de rage ou à damas
trois dames à 8 c surnom il passe pas je
pensais qu'ils allaient faire des 23
dames 1 8t tour g1
j'ai 5 il a raté ça j'ai pas vu non plus
cris talent sueur cris talent sueur face
à super génial orfèvres est ce que
paiera l'eau peut envoyer résista est à
nous avoir
c'est tendu s'est tendue s'est tendu
c'est tendu
heures
e
mais si tu peux faire fou des sacs
poubelles 5 pouces et 6 tu as trois
verbes fer qui avait laissé un et
colmater foot est roi j'aime bien comme
ça surtout prendre un prend et cavaliers
des deux qui a eu quatre j'aime bien
a lieu quatre tours j'ai un cavalier f6
ok ça peut ça peut aller pour berra
l'eau ça peut aller pour berra l'eau
on est à tours angers 1-1 il peut ouvrir
la colonne g il peut envoyer quoi ok là
faut faire c b à froid je pense
thématiques pour fermer le jeu il va y
avoir un bel a cédé à ba3 cette
thématique après faut faire gaffe adams
et ça j'aime pas trop d'un roi b en face
on voit bien je pense un cru utile et
surprise ça laissera plus d'opportunités
en plus pour les blancs prêche pas pour
il fait part d un tempo kessé 80
mentalement je me dis que ab ça va être
chiant dame c4 j'ai pas envie de mettre
madame sur la même colonne que le roi
dont crois bien ça me paraîtrait logique
a prêché par étaient des trucs que je
rate
vous m'avez rendu chèvre vous m'avez
rendu chèvre
qui est peut-être à ba3 qui sait sa
greffe qui est peut-être tour c'est un
qui prend des trois pouces et 7
ça va tomber tours c'est en fait tu
menaces peut-être deux bouffées de force
à bouffer avec le pion ça peut être un
peu risqué a fait danser de dans le même
esprit mesdames ces deux abbés et
maintenant ce que j'aime pas c'est
qu'ils obligent bouffer avec le cavale
mais ce que c'est si vrai sur damas est
le nasdaq prend à deux cavaliers ce
tract où est donc on pourra faire à
trois et ce sera tranquille c'est chaud
et s'il ya un truc comme tourcoing 2 on
apprend damas at échec 3 bougez torah et
vite menace damas mais bon palmarès deux
tours à huit gymnastes rien quoi
et quoique sur quels points dans un
match mais peut-être on peut faire un
truc genre fou bouffe et y'a rien parce
que damas de roisel qu'elle fait hamas
est c'est à dire que à 3 quasi-forcée
hockey fr tourbe et 8 j'imagine qu'elle
tombait 8i des cavaliers bouffe dame
bouffe menace menace perd son père à
l'oa pas défendu de manière magistrale
béral je crois que c'est pas très bien
défendu pitof prendre la tour en machin
jouer des 6,7 faut prendre faire des si
ces machins quoi dame c4 pour colmater
garder le cavalier tour des trois tours
d1 et machin libéral ou qui est pas
hyper efficace
mieux s'il faut prendre ces 5 et roy
devrait aussi possible je reviens à tort
qu'elle a un petit des 6 mai mais bon
roi de aussi possible je pense une vente
d'art entreprises prises des 6 sur ces
quatre prises prise et on peut s'amuser
en faisant dame prend b3 mais qui est
peut-être pas très bon en fait si adam
3e set mais joli variant de 7 offrant
des trois tours des huit buts et 8
bouffe des huit matchs ont du coup
peut-être ces quatre intermédiaires pour
risquer à fond
kim est loin de quais du coup de tête
faut tenter faut à saint-cloud b4
essayer d'aller prendre en forme et il
faut à cinq dames français 5 mai fu v6
du coup vraiment c'est de la merde c'est
mort
cette dame à 4 heures oui mesdames inca
tour c1 dames ses quatre vingts n'y a
pas d'attaquant fait mais des rallyes
qui perd du temps
n'hésitez pas c'est nouveau sur la
chaîne vous abonner je vais peut-être
arrêter un peu dire des couples que
j'aime sans que ça coûte le stream
un petit truc à mathieu corne est ce
parce que du coup je pense à peu un peu
écouté ce que je dis donc je préfère
faire une mare et auteur des coups
pendant deux trois minutes
histoire de laisser faire ah les blancs
sont gagnants mais bon faut encore finir
le taf 1 c'est pas si simple mais je
veux qu'on est assez nombreux sur le
stream ont des 1100 qui est somme toute
un chiffre intéressant ce qui est somme
toute un chiffre intéressant donc
n'hésitez pas à follow la chaîne
marc veyrat loca vraiment pas réussi à
gérer sa finale verra l'eau qui craque
un fait il va quand même la gagner il ya
grosse différence et l'eau parce que tu
faut que tu vas gagner
tout est partie d'échecs bien sûr tu
peux demander à tous les gens qu'il faut
l'eau ici il ya une toutes leurs parties
d'échecs un petit tour des deux échecs
avant cavaliers vii qui va arriver et
qui va menacer le pion aux 5
il n'y a pas qu'à valider si si si ok et
des cistes caillou 5 ou encore à
peut-être qu'il n'existait plus forte
que la rb5 et la tour est en prise
cavaliers des six échecs
sa force c'est sa force et tout
reprendre prix mais peut-être 4 contre
je n'en remets donc du couquet prendre
cinq ans même fort voilà tour cmh
inquiets qui revient 17 probablement
réussir à la gagner bref faire un truc
il aurait de faire un truc super jolie
b4 qui on prend des quatre à quatre et
le roi peut pas rester au contact de la
tour mais je pense qu'il va la gagner
quand même bon an mal an auxquels ils
donnent le pion à accra il craque avec
les noirs des cats dès 5h cinq ans est
là c'est fini ça aura été chaud hein ça
aura été très chaud et la f4 f5 et à
[ __ ] plutôt bref cinq points g63 prend
1,6 on a été des cinq échecs et prend
bekkat la finale est gagnant mais bref 5
c'est plus efficace à court deux lièvres
4 5ème 6ème cette fuite bon victoire de
bérat l'opéra l'eau du coup alors au
classement qu'est ce qui s'est passé ce
que les tanneries méthane il enchaîne
les victoires il gagne plus vite est un
allié fort c'est anne mais l'effort
ferrand où il en est et anne do conde
super génial et ils jouent tous tempo et
1 est à neil a appris comment jouer dans
les arénas
alors
dany gagner vite et il allait il a plus
d'excusé à l'expérience des arénas après
il se met en danger
il faut faire gaffe à la menace c'est
quand même dame g5 fou aux 5 et tu peux
pas faire et si ce palmarès de la sicile
à me ranger cette matt d'avoir ingéré 5
et 6 4 pour gagner contrôler la case et
machin mais a peut-être la tour qui
arrive en b1 si super génial joue bien
ça peut être chaud d'alger 5 et 15 mai à
doké dame g5 qui veut revenir j'ai pas
trop compris f3 keita du g4 maintenant
avec qui des prises prise prise d'alger
5 quaife 5.5 gsi d'un f 6 ouais c'était
mal joué f3 s'est très mal joué et un
qui va gagner et il joue bien cette
année
il joue bien et ann ware est non mais il
a la bonne et la bonne technique pour
les arénas il joue plus vite il mais les
mecs sous l'eau et gagne c'est parti
rapidement aurait pu penser que la
première partie la défaite en 15 minutes
ça aurait pu coûter cher milan envoyé 1
il a envoyé l'envoyer l'envoyer il a
envoyé il a envoyé
c'est elle envoya da
et ça passe le danger quand tu fais ça
ouais après l'aller 3 sont pas très
serré quand je fais ça dans les livres
et arenas à cucq ont des mecs à 2003
2004 et 2006 il ya 200 points mais c'est
plus diffus moins d'écart en fait est
bon des fois je torche le tort je tort
je fais des foyers des partis qui sont
plus dure pas plus de mal à maltraiter
un mec à 2004 qu'un matin à 1000 à 1800
et super génial il n'était pas loin et
n'a pas mal joué mais justin un peu
craqué dès la f3 taquet va devoir faire
face d'eux mêmes cette soirée c'est bien
joué dams et 3 très bien joué de la part
de super génial cet élève ou pro d2 au
super génial super génial
il est la super génial les amis super
génial est en forme allait super génial
allez foot étroite et change tout boum
super génial et la halle et anne quand
même on est pour toi aussi on est pour
tout le monde et la super génial qui
s'est chauffé et monk le roi est super
génial qui peut la gagner relancer le
tournoi
super génial assez dur là pour ethan
parce qu'en plus ces partages sais
jamais quoi faire ce qu en gros c'est
quasi sûr de ne pas gagner si tu fais
nul c'est pas intéressant parce que de
façon tu perds le streak est en revanche
la joue et ça peut durer on va avoir un
mais la partie là elle peut durer bien
une ou deux voire même trois minutes
encore est en fait si tu fais enfin faut
vraiment jouer pour l'arnaqué pour la
gagner quoi sinon ça sert à rien puisque
avec le rajout voyez là à chaque fois
chaque coup ces deux secondes et ça va
jouer encore ça va jouer encore
longtemps qu'ils passent les secondes
qui s'égrènent à l'ail tente un piège
sur foot royal et hourras de ride est
malin il est malin d'ailleurs peut-être
l'arnaqué for iphone a été hué à bonne
école
il commence à tournicoter super génial
qui rame un peu qui a du mal à se
réactive et danica compris quand tu
progresses en finale ça te donne un gros
hedge est obligé de faire deux fous des
deux os non il prend la nulle t'as pas
le droit super génial de prendre là nul
dans cette position avec une pièce de
plus c'est interdit de faire ça si tu
veux progresser aux échecs tu n'as pas
le droit de faire ça tu dois essayer de
la gagner avec la pièce de plus
interdiction n'est de prendre la nulle
dans ses positions et tour g1
les tours g3 il faut tourner mais c'est
nul c'est complètement nul
mais après comme je vous disais pour
ethan même s'il prend un point ou deux
points 2 nuls il a perdu combien de
temps 5
je vais tenter de mettre la tour sur la
sixième à charbon on va voir si c'est
faire la défense de philidor ça va
passer attention bref 5 la torah 5 et
cheikh lô incroyable hein quoi
incroyable incroyable incroyable cours à
6 tours j'ai un échec
comment c'est possible comment c'est
possible
j'en peux plus y me troll c'est pas
ils se parlent entre eux sur dix cornes
ils se parlent entre eux c'est pas
possible il ya un truc les maîtres et
fait roi j'ai six attaques qua non tu
comprends pas fait roi g6 tente quelque
chose et tu fais 5 à 6 j'hallucine
qu'est ce que c'est que ça mais férois
g6 et celle de la gagne et quand même
c'est pas sûr qu'il aurait défendu
j'en peux plus y me troll c'est pas
possible
j'y crois plus j'y crois plus il ya un
complot les mecs il ya un complot il ya
un complot je me fais trop laid c'est
pas possible eh mec je me fais trop laid
il ya quelque chose j'y crois pas j'y
crois pas les mecs chic crois pas il ya
un problème il ya un problème dans cet
aréna
il ya un complot il ya un complot contre
moi c'est pas possible c'est pas
possible
est ce que paiera l'aubade public de
large le monteur le monteur bitstream le
monteur écho plus et là c'est pas
possible
c'est pas possible
j'y crois pas complot c'est les
reptiliens
c'est les reptiliens c'est pas possible
j'y crois plus laid mais qu'est ce que
vous y croyez dans le tchat
il montre au lait mais de chez troller
ils m'ont ils m'ont tué les mecs ils
m'ont tué je vous assure je vous jure
les mecs je comprends rien c'est pas
possible
là on va voir dan b5 échec c'est plus
possible la la je sais complot non mais
là c'est too much qui qui croient en ce
tournoi qui pensent que c'est du vrai
qu'ils pensent que je me fais troll
honnêtement dit - honnêtement c'est pas
dur et les mecs c'est pas du vrai ça me
rappelle des films des fois tu dis ah
non c'est pas possible en vrai et et
c'est pas comme ça elle est à ma quatre
échecs tour d un bon oeil aurait d'amd
cette année c'est tu fais c'est si c'est
ton idée depuis le début mais j'y crois
plus et un complot c'est un complot
encaissé 3 bien joué aussi
il ya eu des paris sur le toit et docks
phc pas y'a un truc
clairement il ya un truc fabi écrit
ouais non mais c'est qu'il ya des gens
qui écrivent sur facebook c'est mathieu
cornette les amis mais franchement je me
suis fait troll de folie sur ce tournoi
incroyable
incroyable j'ai même du mal à conclure
que je reprenne les esprits lave un peu
plus vous m'avez épuisé vous avez tué
ils m'ont épuisé
un truc joli ce qu'avait lieu 8g par
également son amant essaye de faire dame
déçu ce match comme ça c'est mignon le
coup est jolie
mais j'ai plus d'énergie quoi fin des
ragots qui réussit pas à mater les bus
de ville fâche pas à lui de vie qu'il a
beau être monteur et ou au palmarès de
l'unique fille 560 sur chaise comme quoi
fin tu dois quand même battre un mec à
560 plus vite quoi il se bat lui devient
il est là quoi il fait des coups il veut
empêcher berra l'autre gagné le tournoi
quoi vous m'avez tué franchement vous
m'avez tué ce soir sérieux je pense que
c'est le pire tour moi la pire à rennes
qu'on ait joué j'ai jamais vu une arène
on joue aussi mal ça motive à vous
remettre en la prochaine à rennes
bitstream on refait du 3 plus de quoi
c'est pas possible
sérieux c'est pas possible en finale
mais mais mais c'est hallucinant ce que
je vois donc pas j'ai déjà faire du
conte ludique mais ils s'ingénient celui
de lille rival a perdu
rien je te rassure une ligue ligue qui a
perdu alors non le dans le classement
est mais du coup et anna et anne qui est
dans le rouge à cause de la nuit là
méthane qui doit répondre à voir si la
night and day l'appariement contre
marquis c'est pas le marquis de sade ses
marques qui tout court
il a pas l'air d'être très sadique 914
c'est plutôt du masochisme à ce niveau
là c'est vraiment c'est pas le marquis
de sade cessé de marquer
le marquis maso prochain film fait la
gothique bas c'est dans dix jours fous
des deux et pourquoi alors il me troll
tu veux quand même peur d'apprendre et
huit fois f4 quoi veulent pas fou dos
quand même bizarre non mais j'en peux
plus bon peut-être parce qu'il veut
gagner vite extraordinaire c'est extra
bon il y avait une raison mais je suis
épuisée sérieusement g stream et une
heure là palmarès de kevin je suis
épuisé j'ai l'impression de leur stream
et 4h d'être il ya eu il ya trop
d'émotions en fait et à trouillas trop
d'émotions c'est trop pour moi
vous avez réussi à me tuer les mecs
bravo franchement je vous félicite
qu'est ce que c'est que ça qu'est ce que
c'est que ça il enferme le canal il n'y
a pas eu cinq ici massive
bon allez peut-être faut faire d'un
prend d'un projet de rock et tours 8 -
elle est estimée à un peu de jeu mark i
wrote bien joué de la part des tables
qui a signé 7 est maintenant il prend le
fou ouais donc et anne qui va gagner
c'est la joue entre et anne hébert à
l'eau en libéral auquel s'adonnent mais
berra l'eau y réfléchit longtemps en
fait marc en temps sur un fait pas
qu'ils aient progressé de 7 à un
problème de maths kiwi pas ce qui est
peut-être en train de passer quoi des
quatre bêtement je suis en sueur ouais
je vais me remettre en question j'ai
avec les scream pédagogique et bien sûr
non mais les finales c est parce qu on
vous ment en 3 0 en fait on les voit pas
les finales mais là quand on voit les
finales c'est vous passez pas à jouer
d'un f3 par contre c'est bien mais il
veut faire d'un problème cette dame est
fluide d'alger cette dame croit je suis
tout ça c'était bien joué mais à qui les
français de vos pieds de france et de ce
qui va le voir
non non
vous
l'as pas vu je vais commenter comme ça à
cacher par le tee shirt je veux plus
voir ça je veux pouvoir ça j'en peux
plus je n'en veux pas plus qu'un
français 2 il me troll c'est pas
possible qu'ils veulent me tuer
ils veulent me tuer ils veulent
m'achever il fallait achever les mecs
s'il vous plaît les mecs arrêtez ça
aurait pu tout arrêter tous les mecs
arrêtez tous les mecs
j'en peux plus j'en veux plus je ne fus
pas ramer le x x précession c'est sur
moi j'y crois pas moi j'y crois pas
voilà béral aux estivales à gagner
game studios l'on puisse vous fait rire
je change pas mais demain je vais chez
le coiffeur ils sont trop longs bâiller
vont tuer fait j'arrive m'a plu a
commenté j'arrive même plus à regarder
les mecs ggg le syndrome j'arrive plus
quoi j'arrive plus les mecs à je suis
désolé j'arrive pas à commenter cette
fin de tournoi c'est trop c'est trop
je comprends pas ce qui s'est passé les
mecs sais pas s'il ya un vaudou qui est
venu je sais pas il va vivre à se
prendre pour un f2 vous allez voir il
car on joue au flipper flipper le
dauphin
même mes blagues sont plus drôles à
l'effet du flipper famille géniale le
figaro qu'elle y jouent tient pas je
vois le stream sur portable il est
extraordinaire ce flipper
c'est assez marrant mais la raison du
conflit peur aussi j'aurais faire du
flipper intéressant de flipper c'est
très intéressant le flipper mais très
énervé moyens de bien se mettre une
boule
je crois qu'ils les 1200 flipper
franchement je crois qu'il n'est pas
plus fort que vous au flipper hummer
d'être assez nul au flipper pas que là
il s'est bien battu et se bat bien
hikaru au flipper grâce à me détendre
regarde un peu de flipper là franchement
vous m'avez sauvé quoi h santé qui
laisse le prendre pour un f2 vous avait
prévenu
il n'a pas l'air d'être très très bon il
est en sueur à chaque coup de la rampe
ce qui donnera des supers réflexe du
comment ils jouent en bullet salle mais
tellement sur le flipper c'est
extraordinaire il se bat pas mal quand
même
n'allez pas mauvais il a tellement
toujours peur que la balle tombe au
milieu ça se sent pas marrant c'est
l'icao nuageux l'aréna kings ont fusé
est très heureuse
j'étais super bon dans un mois ce
flipper de folie là le flipper windows
ouais il est bon il est bon il est
solide servie joue pas mal gt gt pas
mauvais il y jouera un enfant vous faire
un tour à 6 tours prend dès 6h15 mais la
franchement j'ai besoin de faire une
petite pause quoi désolé les mecs
j'arrive plus à j'arrive plus à assumer
vos nombreuses erreurs en fait j'assume
plus est ce que paiera l'eau va gagner
alors au classement et anne pierre prix
lilas et anne qui s'est envolé méthane
il est fort il s'est gagné beaucoup de
parties à tient contre le charpentier
est ce que le charpentier va lui refaire
la charpente partie importante
ça va ça pour le charpentier prisé eux
quatre ils connaissent un charpentier
dame c-26 jouable
non il est pas mal à le charpentier là
il a pris l'avantagé d'un point ces
affaires des 3rocs machin il est bien là
le charpentier à pourquoi fout d'eux
c'est trop passifs foot est roi à sous
plus actif charpentier et cavaliers 5
machin aller d'am-dam b2 ou dame b 1
t'aurais le fou en d3 tu ferais dame b
un tour c'est un cavalier e 5 es tu
commenceras a tapé rien il ya eu depuis
tant que tu joues le système de long de
charpentier là qu'est ce que c'est que
ça se fout de la la j'ai envie de te
mettre des calottes assis et en face de
moi à charpentier j'ai envie de lui
mettre des petites carottes
ça fait des années qu'ils jouent le
système de l'ombre et il fait foods 2
j'aurais pu mettre des calottes du coup
la dame et océans lieu d'être en b1
mais bon ça va encore il fait il joue
pas trop mal et il connaît quelques
plans c'est pas si dès que tu as eu lui
mettre des petites calotte c5 tâte un
peu tôt et ont pu commencer par
cavaillon e5 est parce qu il ya trouvé
cinq noms mais allez food et ringarde le
fou peut-être pas même je sais pas trop
prématuré elle est épuisée
honnêtement je me sens épuisé la trop
d'émotions
trop plein d'émotions baklava lieux
saints gagne un tempo pourquoi je crois
quoi ça sert voyez vous gardez vous
allez on va dire que ça va mais bon qui
avait trois tu vas tenir long truc dam
des deux cavaliers cinq cavaliers à 5
allée kébé trois dates des deux places
les pièces ce turbo le calvaire à
saint-claude 05 assez dur de placer les
pièces 1 tab ces deux tu restes en face
de la tour palmarès de dames ces deux
jeux je conserve un clouage pour
martelly et b3 d'amd de gizeh de la mer
des cavaliers 4 mais bon allez qui est
b3 yves alain cavalier
tu aimes pas de faire une pause soirée
n'a kingwell je vais essayer de manger
de soi mais franchement l'aréna king ce
soir ça va pas être possible
vous m'en avez fait trop à voir de
toutes les couleurs vous m'avez vous
m'avez tué quoi t'es tu dis n'importe
quoi sur cette partie puisque le truc
était tellement à l'envers au curé qui y
est logée commencer les échecs cette
semaine après être tombé sur ton stream
sur twitch pointé vers lui alors il te
dire bravo je suis à 1250 points environ
c'est bien je suis pas spécialement
bloqué à ce niveau mais est ce que tu
aurais de bonnes ressources pour
rapidement s'améliorer bas les vidéos
youtube a déjà et l'abonnement diamant
check point comme c'est bien
non sérieux et m'ont fait mal sarrio ils
m'ont fait mal les mecs vont kettani les
grands leaders et ce avec berra l'on en
fait il aurait pu gagner le tournoi mon
avis jouer bien aujourd'hui berra l'eau
parce que berra l'eau on va on va suivre
la partie des terres on ira voir ça de
berrahal au méthane c'est pas sûr qu'il
va de charpentier et charpente il peut
tenir sa il pas mauvais charpentier et
franchement il joue pas mal hein allégé
cap charpentier allez courage gk3 h2
tour g1 d'alger 2 on va mater on doit
changer le côté du jeu maintenant
charpentier fallait attaquer le roi tu
as une pièce de plus le cavalier les
bloquer en b5 et tu vas a défoncé le roi
si tu peux peut-être pas surfer
peut-être faire j'ai quatre plus tôt
peut-être perdu un thème pour important
une fois je 2g quatre matches et j'ai
cinq cavaliers
pourquoi oui va avec le caïque et en d3
a été fantastique
il contre le saint qui contrôlait tout
qu'est ce que c'est que ça
bon allez c'est chaud encore des tours
b1 et on prend bessette
non mais pas mal il un jeu stratégique
intéressant charpentier sept souffre rb6
ici profiter du clm et faut calculer ses
six têtes un peu dangereux - faire
tourner un rapide hausse
et il n'a pas le temps mais
la dame en a quatre très probablement si
l'un peut clouer bloquer tout ça ou
d'amd de encore mieux pour gagner le
pion ça j'avais pas vu non plus
charpentier qui a utilisé du temps à
prendre 5 de toute façon avec le pion et
il y aura pas tour c'est cette parce
qu'il ya eu 6 c peut calculer quand même
merde quand même flash donnait points on
prend 1,5 quand même pas rester logique
est maintenant sûr qu'ils ont trouvé
cinq cadavres six tu as perdu un tempo
et fois ci les coups les plus simples
les meilleurs après je suis pas sûr que
c'était vraiment très bien mais bon t'as
pas des 5,50
il a tout donné et charpentier je fais
une bonne partie stratégique c'est pas
mal et tu fais des cas de la canada quoi
on croirait le psg contre manchester va
ce qu'il a fait le charpentier à tour
est même des cas se fait changer les
dames et filles à quoi que dame prend
des quatre sur qui les prend des quatre
fous prendre 5 fourchette
non non gagné
je fais trop les par les mots d une part
mais modo maintenant après c'est pas sûr
il y avait peut-être moyen de défendre
il y avait probablement dame prend prise
fou prend cave a lieu deux échecs croit
f2 et tour ici fou des six tours aussi
s'échanger je sais pas si ça perdez ou
pas mais en tout cas il a raté la prise
et le fourrage de en plus c'est le fou
du système de londres à vous m'avez fait
souffrir aujourd'hui
après peut-être penser ça qui a
peut-être des trucs mais bon il a pas vu
quoi charpentières dommage parce qu'il
joue pas mal aller bien sûr c'est
pardonnable un les mecs on rigole alain
tu pas sûr que les gens comprennent des
fois qu'on est à la limite du second
degré mais pas toujours second degré d'
oncle aujourd'hui ce que certains trucs
c'était quand même un peu spécial la
première partie où quoi et des trucs
spéciaux
sinon on rigole 1 on a eu des trucs un
peu spéciaux aujourd'hui bon alors c'est
à dire que acer qui est fan peut gagner
le tournoi
ça dépend fédéral au gagne la dernière
pour le raser sur le poteau vers à l'eau
qui peut gagner une pièce de plus mais
il reste 3 25
normalement berra l'eau soit versée à sa
défense son adversaire est sympa qui lui
laisse la victoire parce qu'il joue pour
plus rien si son adversaire est un con
comme moi et qui décide de proposer nul
et jouer la montre ça et tout est dans
les mains de thomas est dans les mains
de l'adversaire d'éthane qui va le jouer
à la prochaine
car qui n'en ok merci est-ce que tu
conseilles de se concentrer sur un
opening pour chaque couleur au début
pour vraiment les maîtriser oui bien sûr
un tue mais essayez d'utiliser un peu
moins d'anglicismes les mecs je remarque
que vous parlez beaucoup avec des mots
anglais quand c'est pas utile tu vas tu
peux utiliser ouverture le d'opening je
remarque à beaucoup de gens qui parlent
comme ça c'est à moins que vous viviez
en angleterre on dans un pays anglo
saxon mais c'est un peu bizarre donc
d'utiliser deux sans arrêt des
anglicismes pour tous même si même moi
je le fais peut-être mais je me dis ouah
c'est un peu c'est un peu too much as
envie de te dire comme ça je suis un
anglicisme aussi mais tu as pour les
échecs sont plus simples non mais bon
ici ce zambie 6 mais bon je remarque
parfois que un opening on peut dire
comme une ouverture
bon vous faites comme vous voulez un non
mais moi je le fais aussi mais je le dis
dès fois c'est un peu abusé on peut
quand un des mots français qui
correspondent bien c'est intéressant
juste aura la berra l'eau est gagnant
mais est-ce que son adversaire mal à
jouer
ouais c'est sûr y'a pas eu laisser
gagner il va falloir gagner vers alloué
il n'a pas la gagner il va finir 2e est
affirmé heny sur 14 ans sur 2 ha et il
aurait peut-être mérité de gagner mais
bon et thann qui a bien réussi à
arnaquer notre ami charpentier un peu de
réussite pour étendre sur le tournoi
s'est bien joué c'est tout à son honneur
mais rallo un poil en manque un peu
d'effet d'efficacité contre les joueurs
plus faible mais bon du coup il prend
moins de risques
c'est une belle arena en tout cas elle a
par exemple qui est proche d'eux c'est
bien joué mais photo f 5 f4 fallait
envoyer quoi parce que le truc c'est
qu'il va jamais gagné 150 secondes même
si son adversaire
l'ajout sympa et qu'il a abandonnée au
moment où il doit abandonner
tout cas c'était difficile c'était
difficile on a bien rigolé gens
comprennent que c'est du semis second
degré voilà peut-être tout reprendre et
6 d'âme des uns et dame prend à eux deux
ce qui va le voir
oui est-ce que ça adversaire va
abandonner ou pas si son adversaire est
sympa il abandonne 6 et une tête de mule
comme moi lille attend il propose nul
passé une tête de mule il est pas sympa
son adversaire mais bon puis-je
reprochait à thomas ne pas abandonner
avec une tour une pièce de moins hayden
la dame grauss et le beau jeu
olala it roll it roll heil à troller
thomas mais bon on peut pas on peut pas
on peut pas reprocher à à thomas d'avoir
trop j'aurais fait pareil que lui
c'est beau c'est beau c'est ces gens
l'esprit libéral aurait dû prendre
l'annuler prendre de points il ya il
aurait fini à égalité avec ethan mais
bon fallait le savoir fallait faire un
nul prendre les points
bon bah j'espère vous êtes bien amusé
suisse est nouveau sur le stream
n'hésitez pas à mettre n pequeno follow
qui fait plaisir on se retrouve bien
évidemment à 21h06